hello everyone i'm tsuyoshi konda the
producer of resident evil village thanks
to all of our fans village has sold over
6 million units worldwide
everyone on the team is incredibly happy
to see so many people enjoy the game
thank you for your support
the resident evil series continues to
bring fun experiences to people around
the world
we want long time fans and people who
are new to resident evil to enjoy this
storied franchise
let's start with this video
it's all right
i can show you things even chris doesn't
know what i can do
i want to live a normal life
shut up
[Music]
is going on
[Music]
you just like
me
oh now we have a new little rabbit to
place
[Applause]
it's time
marking the target
it's showtime
now
what next
[Applause]
sorry to keep you waiting
we're happy to reveal the dlc for
resident evil village we promised last
year
we think this new experience will be
worth the wait
this dlc includes three major features
first the third person mode
many people asked for this and we were
able to add it into the game now you'll
be able to see ethan as he desperately
fights for survival players that have
already experienced ethan's journey can
enjoy the new perspective and animations
too the mercenaries returns with
additional orders in an arcade-style
action game where focus has been put on
the exhilarating feeling of defeating
relentless hordes of enemies new stages
are included as well as additional
playable characters such as chris
redfield and heisenberg of course lady
dimitresk will be there too we've really
fueled this mode up
enjoy looking down on your foes from
over nine feet above as lady dimitresk
slashes her enemies aside
the third edition is one you've surely
been waiting for an additional story
shadows of rose today let me introduce
just a bit of this story
rose the beloved daughter of the main
protagonist ethan is now a grown-up main
character in this new story mode
in this sequel to the main story of
village you can experience rose's
struggles with the terrifying power she
was born with to break free of the curse
of her powers she enters the
consciousness of the mega my seat
there she meets a girl who looks just
like her
in this mysterious realm of
consciousness time and space is warped
beyond recognition rose is guided by a
being who calls himself michael who
might be of assistance with removing her
powers
shadows of rose is set completely in a
third person perspective in the realm of
consciousness you won't only face
creatures but the world itself seems to
be attacking you
enjoy the horror of the world itself
being your greatest enemy
how will rose find freedom from her
mysterious powers
the dlc for resident evil village
winters expansion includes all three of
these major additions
in addition resident evil village gold
edition a bundle of winter's expansion
with the face game will be released
simultaneously the release date is
planned for october 28
2022 resident evil reverse will also
begin service on the same date october
28 2022 we hope that you are looking
forward to it
how did you like that
also as already announced we are working
on making the main story of village
available on mac so that even more
people can enjoy resident evil
in addition the main story of village is
planned to be playable on playstation
vr2
we're working hard on bringing you the
ultimate immersive experience worthy of
next gen in resident evil village
so look forward to future announcements